[Musique]
récit le cardinal est ton chemin
il arrive de rome le shérif à lui
organisé un banquet de winne qui est
actif c'est mon jour de congé aucun
confié l'anglais
tu te reposes il vient à cause du voleur
masqué notre plan fonctionne c'est plus
facile à dire pour toi pour moi le
cardinal est l'un des hommes les plus
puissants du monde
alors ce qu'il s'apprête à dire au
shérif on doit le savoir est ce que tu
entends par là que je dois le savoir un
flamboyant bal masqué l'endroit parfait
pour voir si le charme de loxley opère
encore on a mis la maison on va voir qui
mord
ouah le coffre des impôts là sous notre
nez pendant le service du dimanche au et
aussi les droits de passage de la nuit
dernière alors qui d'autre est au
courant je suis venu directement chez
vous mais il faut prévenir l'archidiacre
à mon âge ne me ment il faut éviter
qu'il avait tout raconté au cardinal
mais monseigneur l'église doit savoir de
loi de sécurité
je représente la loi et la sécurité je
ne peux pas me permettre de perdre notre
pays
chérif je ne vous ai pas entendu depuis
longtemps confession ma conscience est
tranquille et là votre gsm est la mienne
est un petit peu confuse et bien tâcher
de bien ouvrir les oreilles dans votre
petit confessionnal si le voleur se
confesse ramener le mois avec tout le
respect que je vous dois le secret de la
confession est sacrée rien ne sera sacré
tant que je n'aurais pas réussi à
enfermer ce voleur dans une cage
tu n'es plus robin de locksley
dans des bois tu étais un homme est à
présent qu'il va devenir un voleur
et je vais te montrer comment
cite moi je t'en prie
il faut que tu sois guéri pour le but
que ça qu'est ce que tu fais avec mon
manteau
encore quand est-ce que je commence
enfin à voler quoi
c'est tout ce que tu as il y à des
bruits qui courent
sur un voleur je fais respecter la loi
je veux qu'on me rapporte tout ce qui
est dit sur ce voleur
il y a qu une chose qu ils maintiennent
au pouvoir l'argent on va le volet je
veux voler le trésor du royaume organise
une réunion avec tous ceux qui sont avec
nous c'est notre chance
voilà le plan
tu va agir de l'intérieur tuer un homme
à profit toit du jury vous savez qui est
ce voleur
apparemment quelqu'un devient entraîneur
et que le combat ne ferai pas vous
finirez par l'avoir
notre plan fonctionne il va mordre la
passe
je vais leur rappeler qu'ils ne sont pas
le peuple mais qui sont mes sujets
salut du suicide
il faut pas ce qu'on fait
vous êtes un modèle pour le peuple
mais celui qui me lie pour acheter malin
tous super maintenant si on se fait
prendre ils nous tueront tout
c'est très motivant merci tu n'es plus
robin de locksley
robin des bois